so the banking would have today cut
interest rates from nor point five
percent for not point 25 that's the
lowest level in history but perhaps more
significant than the rate cut is the
expanded QE there's another sixty
billion of QE + 10 billion buying a
corporate bonds
but as a question I think about how
effective this interest rate cut is
going to be first of all it's only a
quarter of a percent cut so not actually
that baking in historical terms the next
thing is does this actually boost
consumer confidence or does it add to
people's sense but they're not quite
sure what's going on and then and it
might be better to hold onto their money
right now rather than spend it
well I mean there was always going to be
a period of short-term economic
uncertainty after practice after all at
the moment no one is quite aware of what
the nature of the UK's trading
relationship with the rest of you will
be once it leaves I begin the current
economic vogue knowledgeable he was
always going to be what was mainly used
to try and bridge that gap but I mean
there are some questions about the
effectiveness of monetary policy at the
moment with this interest rate cut how
how will that go down will at first add
to the sensor nodes quite sure what's
going on and I mean there is also some
concerns about the way which q has
worked over the last few years whoever
it is you know simply pushed our past
set prices are exacerbating some of the
problems been a policy that they tried
to deal with in the economy at the
moment